67000 عامل في قطاع التكنولوجيا الامريكي
تم الاستغناء عن خدماتهم خلال العام
الجاري حتى منتصف نوفمبر واللوم على
عمليات التوظيف المكثفه خلال الوباء بخلاف
التضخم وارتفاع اسعار الفائده واليكم
المزيد من الارقام نحو 50 بالمئه من القوى
العامله لتويتر تم تصريحهم بعد ايام من
ثمانيه الى الماسك صفقه استح
واذ التغريدات احد عشر الف موظف او نحو
13% هو عدد الموظفين الذين كانوا متى
الاستغناء عنهم في جميع انحاء العالم وهي
اول عمليه تسريح جماعي في تاريخ الشركه
10,000 موظفت امازون لتسريحهم في حسب
تقارير صادره عن عده صحف ومئت موظف من
شركه اوريكن نحو الف موظف هو عدد موظفين
الذين استغنت عنهم مايكروسوفت في جميع
انحاء العالم هو يقال ان السبب هو تراجع
مبيعات ويندوز لاجهزه الكمبيوتر هو واخيرا
تخطط انت لتصريح الاف الموظفين مع انخفاض
لشحنات الربع الثالث من اجهزه الكمبيوتر
خلال العام خمسه عشر بالمئه مقارنه بالعمل
الماضي